all right what's the definition of
delicate raise your hand all our
students have spent some time in a
refugee camp so some of our students
have seen war and never been in a school
before
but kids are much more resilient and
much more hopeful than adults
coach luma founded the fuji's academies
the only school system for refugees in
the united states
for her creating a school where
displaced children could thrive was very
personal
my name is luma mufle i'm ceo and
founder of the fuji's family and i'm an
immigrant from jordan
[Music]
my name is minnie driver i am an actress
a singer and i am an immigrant i believe
nothing is more american than its
immigrants
so i'm teaming up with great big story
to celebrate those that have come here
and left their mark
oh
come on
i think giving up my citizenship was the
hardest thing i've ever had to do
i'm gay and in jordan you can get the
death penalty for being gay and the us
allows you to claim asylum
to know that a country you love doesn't
want you
it's really hard
coach luma moved to the united states in
college she played soccer growing up so
when she met a group of young refugees
playing the sport it reminded her of
home
she decided to form a team for them that
team name was the fujis
we're reclaiming the word refugee we
want to be proud of it we don't want it
to have the stigma of shame and it's
about finding a common identity for
everybody who's had to leave their
country
[Music]
as luma grew to love these kids she soon
realized they weren't getting the
attention they needed in the public
school system their parents couldn't
help them with their homework because
most of them hadn't received a high
school education
so they would ask looma for help
i quickly realized that if they've
attended public school those experiences
were not positive
i said you know if this was my child
what would i do
in 2004 she created a school that
catered to the needs of these children
and she named it the fuji's academy
luma recruited most of her students on
the soccer field and soon enough news of
the school spread
the fuji's academies represent over 32
different ethnic groups
we can't do bilingual education because
we'd have to have over 30 languages
represented the immersion approach works
i think it's actually easier to teach
english to people who speak different
languages because it's commonality
they're also surrounded by kids that
have the same experience and so they're
not going to be made fun of if they
don't know the language or if they have
an accent and the fuji's academies take
great pride in meeting the kids at their
grade level regardless of their age
can you get out your study guides please
in our sixth grade class you'll see us
teaching what would typically be taught
in a kindergarten first grade classroom
and then by seventh grade it's third and
fourth grade and then by eighth grade
they're catching up to grade level
our standard is very high for them
because we know what it takes to make it
in this country
loomis priority is to break the cycle of
poverty for these families in the united
states we do
really talk about the commonality of
having to flee your country and it's
very powerful and what we're going to
see with their families and the
generations after is going to be
incredible
[Music]
every year since 2016 over 95 of her
seniors graduate with a high school
diploma a first for most of the families
in the audience
i think their graduation day is a symbol
of america for all our families
in some ways this might be the american
dream
my name is tenha i was born in oakland a
refugee camp in thailand my name is hara
hassan eventually will be dr hara hassan
i'm the first in my family to finish
elementary school middle school high
school and now attend college i'm the
first in my village to make it this far
and i'll keep on going
i think it's a very dangerous narrative
to feel sorry for refugees because the
mere fact that they are here shows how
strong they are
[Music]
in 2018 luma opened a second school in
columbus ohio
but it's loomer's dream to have a school
in every refugee resettlement hub in the
country if you create opportunities for
them to thrive i mean they're going to
accomplish the impossible because look
at what they've survived
i think that's what a coach does is like
you believe
in the ability of that person
that you start believing that these
things are possible
[Music]
you